this video was brought to you by
manscapes.com but more on that in a
moment
[Music]
these images are horrific and speak for
themselves faced with failure on the
battlefield one of Russia's latest
strategies in Ukraine is to blatantly
attack the civilian population in order
to leave them without light and heat on
the brink of the harsh Ukrainian winter
a winter in which temperatures range on
average between -5 and 2 degrees Celsius
which is roughly 23 to 36 degrees
Fahrenheit well it is estimated that by
mid-november 2022 around 40 of Ukraine's
entire power generation infrastructure
will have been destroyed and according
to the Ukrainian government itself it's
likely to get worse zelenski Russia has
damaged 40 percent of Ukraine's energy
infrastructure Ukraine warns of more
attacks on infrastructure as mayor urges
Kiev to prepare for the worst during the
Autumn Putin's troops have been using
their few remaining missiles and
precision bombs along with suicide
drones purchased from Iran to destroy
water plants power plants thermal
thermoelectric and hydroelectric plants
and this is key in a country where the
heating of most people living in urban
areas depends on the heat that is Gen
generated centrally in these plants in
other words we're not only talking about
the electricity Supply but also about
heating itself
crane as in so many other places most
people do not have boilers at home
instead heat and hot water are generated
in large power plants and then
distributed through pipes to the homes
themselves well the result of the
Russian attacks in both Kiev and many
other cities are suffering severe energy
restrictions fewer heating hours Street
lighting is not turned on or only
minimally and many businesses are unable
to operate or can only operate
intermittently and naturally apart from
the cold and the difficulties that
people are experiencing and doing
something as simple as being able to
cook we also have to take into account
the damage to economic activity
foreign
with the arrival of autumn and winter
the war in Ukraine has turned into a war
of attrition against the civilian
population given at this point the
Russian army seems convinced that they
do not have much chance of Victory on
the battlefield itself what we are
seeing therefore is the use of climate
as a weapon of War as simple as that
Putin wants to use the cold to provoke
waves of discontent and weariness
amongst ukrainians because the truth is
that one of the few options left of the
Kremlin to at least try to back out of
this conflict is the ukrainians
themselves to say enough is enough and
force the lenses government to negotiate
this clearly seems to be the Russian
dictator's bet
but beyond moscow's plans the reality
however may be completely different
[Music]
surprising as it may seem the truth is
that the Ukrainian winter may turn out
to be a nightmare for Russian troops
instead as much as ukrainians are forced
to be cold and live in semi-darkness the
Russians may end up taking the brunt of
it and the question is why isn't the
winter always supposed to favor the
Russians how can the arrival of cold
snow and extreme conditions really
influence the battlefield which side
stands to benefit or hurt the most we're
going to tell you all of this and more
in this video but before I go any
further let me tell you about something
else this year Christmas has come early
for all of us here at visualpolitik we
just got the performance package 4.0
from manscaped shall we take a look at
it this hygiene and shaving kit from
manscape covers all your needs from head
to toe literally for starters includes
the Crown Jewel the lawnmower 4.0
waterproof cordless trimmer with its
Advanced Skin safe technology that helps
reduce cuts and snags on the most
sensitive areas of the body it comes
with a handy LED light for when shaving
on those cold dark winter nights this
kit also includes the weed whacker the
nose and ear hair trimmer with 360
degree rotating blades the moment you
start using it you'll realize you won't
know how to live without it but that's
not all home you'll also find crop
preserver intimate deodorant and crop
reviver intimate toner spray and as if
that wasn't enough you'll also receive
two free gifts this toiletry bag and a
pair of manscaped anti-chafing boxers
and as always we have a very special
discount for all of you who follow us
here on visualpolitics for a limited
time only you can get 25 off sitewise at
manscapes.com during the manscaped Black
Friday sale plus free international
shipping and two free gifts when you
bundle use Pro wheel code VPN at
manscape.com and shop today and now
let's get back to the video
General winter
[Music]
okay historically winter has been one of
the great allies of the Russian bear
for example in 1812 Napoleon's Grand
Army was defeated in Russia by winter
suffering some 380 000 losses both from
the fighting itself as well as from
starvation and hypothermia a little more
than a century later in 1941 during
World War II a well-known dictator
condemned his troops to an even worse
debacle Hitler made the same mistake as
Napoleon throwing himself into the arms
of the Russian winter without his army
being accustomed to the conditions or
suitably prepared something that ended
up costing the wear Max to suffer heavy
defeats tens and tens of thousands of
lives were lost along the way
of course this is not the whole story
through its history Russia has also had
bad experiences with the frigid winter
season for example in 1939 during the
winter war between the Soviet Union and
Finland the Soviets had to desist from
invading all of Finland after losing
between 130 and 160 000 men although at
least in this case they got a treaty
that seated them some finished bits and
pieces especially in the corellia and
Salah regions
[Music]
well although winter has usually been an
ally for Moscow the Russian situation in
Ukraine could end up being very similar
to what happened in Finland in 1939 or
even worse worse because the collapse of
the Russian front in kharkiv and Kirsten
along with the bottleneck and the Don
bass did not occur in winter but during
the summer and Autumn and during those
months naturally the weather was not a
relevant Factor the Russian disaster has
been brought about primarily by the
technological superiority and
intelligence applied to Ukraine by its
Western allies in addition to the
tremendous tenacity of the ukrainians
themselves of course it's an advantage
that the winter could now even
accentuate the fact is that the winter
season could make things much worse for
the Russians although naturally it
wouldn't be a piece of cake for the
ukrainians either a war in such a winter
is not plain sailing for anyone but now
the question is why do we give so much
prominence to Winter how could this cold
season affect the course of the war well
without further Ado let's take a look
a poisoned gift
this time is not the Russians who are
suffering from the invasion of foreign
powers but they themselves are the
Invaders this has many implications that
could work against them and keep in mind
the Kremlin knows it and so with the end
of Summer and the arrival of autumn they
have tried to increase the pressure by
attacking civilian targets but to tell
you exactly why the Ukrainian winter may
end up turning into a nightmare for
Putin the Kremlin and the Russian troops
let's highlight four main reasons and
yes the first of them has a lot to do
with the theater of operations itself or
rather with fighting outside Russia we
are talking of course about supplies to
the Troops although this war is
concentrated in the Border areas which
are in theory the ones that Russia can
supply best the truth is that in winter
this mission may not be easy at all the
reason you see is that a good part of
the front especially that of the Kirsten
region is far from Russia's Supply and
production centers despite being so
close to Crimea because even eight years
after its annexation Crimea is still
supplied mainly from Russia and let's
see while it is true that other conflict
zones such as the Donetsk oblask do have
a good connections with for example
roster vondon a large Russian industrial
city of more than one million
inhabitants the rest of the front is not
so lucky
[Music]
in any case having to move heavy
equipment and large shipments of all
kinds of supplies over frozen ground and
Roads is usually not an easy task so in
Winter Russia will be even more
dependent on rail transports the problem
is that the railway Lanes beside being
much more rigid simply do not reach
everywhere there are also more exposed
than the roads and if the ukrainians
managed to cut them off with attacks and
sabotage then the Russians may see
problems they already have in supplying
their army multiply and obviously a lack
of supplies in Winter can be decisive by
contrast the ukrainians are playing on
home turf and that in logistical terms
is a huge advantage
but that's not all to fight in Winter
you need two things preparation and
equipment
[Music]
these things are more challenging than
battling in Sub-Zero temperatures and
dealing with snow ice and frost well
here the ukrainians may have the upper
hand and on this point well I think many
of you already know the story Russian
mobilized troops poorly trained lacked
proper gear for war Western Intel
Russia's mobilized soldiers speak out we
were thrown on the front line with no
support the enormous number of
casualties suffered which Western
sources estimate for example had been
100 000 men between dead and wounded has
made the Russians pool in forced
recruits
foreign
ERS recently mobilized at full speed who
in many cases have received practically
no training before being sent to the
front and even those who have been more
fortunate have barely received any
preparation at all and yes you might
think that the ukrainians are facing a
very similar situation however there's
some important differences here first
playing at home and fighting in your own
cities is not the same as doing it in a
foreign country without knowing the
terrain without the support of the
population and with morale at Rock
Bottom secondly today Ukraine has more
professionally experienced soldiers on
the battlefield than Russia in this
respect the territorial Defense Forces
have been a massive success and thirdly
many Ukrainian soldiers professional
soldiers are Soldiers with some combat
experience are receiving first-rate
training for example the British have
been training Ukrainian troops for
months and now many other European
countries have started to do the same EU
countries agree to train Ukrainian
soldiers as part of a new Mission So in
theory it seems that we're talking about
know-how the ukrainians have an
advantage over the Russians and that is
something that is worth double in the
winter time
but let's continue the third major
reason has to do precisely with the
equipment available to the soldiers
themselves virtually from the beginning
of the Russian invasion of Ukraine one
of the things that has attracted the
most attention is that many Russian
soldiers do not have advanced individual
equipment and as the month have gone by
this has only gotten worse the Russian
army has given newly drafted soldiers
absolutely no equipment forcing families
to buy armor and clothing so conscripts
have a chance to come back we now know
that nine months after the beginning of
the invasion the Russian army warehouses
are trembling there is a shortage of
missiles of modern tanks of ammunition
and yes also of individual equipment
[Music]
fighting an extremely cold icy and snowy
conditions requires specific equipment
for example soldiers boots have to be
able to withstand low temperatures and
to walk on ice and clothing has to be
thermal yet lightweight to allow
movement given the climatic conditions
in Russia we might think that its Army
is well supplied with these things but
the truth is that everything indicates
that this is not the case the Chronicles
that are reaching us from the front
point out that the new Russian soldiers
arrive practically empty-handed and it
follows that modern equipment is
conspicuous by its absence
[Music]
meanwhile the ukrainians have been
receiving tons of individual winterized
equipment from their Western allies for
months already so it is very likely that
the Kiev Army is already covered NATO is
rushing equipment to Ukraine as troops
hunker down for the winter western
countries are speeding up shipments of
winter clothing new rounds of artillery
and counter drone defenses to Kiev as
Ukrainian and Russian forces prepare for
a month's long grind amid the mud and
ice and guess what exactly the same is
true for heavy military hardware
[Music]
foreign Ukraine when the first snowfalls
begin they accumulate and turn into hard
ice that remains almost until the
arrival of spring and after the ice
comes the mud which can end up being
even worse all of this makes both armies
much more likely to use the roads which
are usually kept cleaner or at least are
easier to clean instead of trying to
advance cross-country or on Rural roads
basically because getting around there
can be hell in fact I don't know if you
remember that in February and March
during the first month of the invasion
when there was still snow in ice in
Ukraine the Russians were always
advancing on the main roads and that was
one of the reasons why their long
convoys became very vulnerable do you
remember when Russian trucks and armored
vehicles were trapped because their
tires exploded due to being out of date
do you remember the Ukrainian ambushes
that ended with numerous pieces of
Russian equipment burned to ashes well
that's just it and don't forget that all
of this happened in February and March
when the Russians had more resources at
the disposal and a more favorable
difference with respect to Ukrainian
troops so imagine what could happen now
you could say that during this winter
something similar could be repeated
something similar but definitely not the
same
[Music]
you see the Russians know all too well
that their old-fashioned tanks armor and
trucks don't do well off-road in winter
so you're likely to see less fighting in
the open Countryside in addition winter
weather conditions are much more adverse
such as rain snowfall storms or fog
which hinder the operation of drones so
necessary for both sides in order to fix
targets and use Precision weapons for
this reason one of the possibilities
being considered for the winter is that
the war although it would actually stop
will enter a kind of Snooze phase in
which the operations we see will be on a
much smaller scale and developments will
be much slower at the same time however
the harsh winter conditions and more
complicated movements through the
terrain make the equipment suffer much
more
and do you know what none of this plays
in the Russians favor either a longer
War requires continuous Supply effort
and then with the additional wear and
tear on equipment the Russians may have
a lot more problems basically due to the
fact that Ukraine has more modern heavy
weaponry and even without that their
equipment is usually maintained in
better condition
for example many of the t-72 tanks used
by Ukraine today were donated by Poland
and have been delivered in perfect
working condition after being
reconditioned and the same goes for
other tanks and weapons from countries
such as the Czech Republic for example
and not only that Ukraine's allies in
the region such as Poland Slovakia and
the Czech Republic puncturally repair
Ukrainian military equipment and even
update it we are talking about a chain
of Maintenance updates and modernization
of weapons that has been created on the
Fly and that is allowing the ukrainians
to be a few steps ahead of the Russians
obviously we cannot know what exactly is
going to happen but visualpolitik
viewers everything indicates that this
time the winter does not favor the
kremlin's interests and perhaps that is
precisely why we have seen and continue
to see how Russia's new gamble in this
war is to bring the ukrainians to the
negotiating table once and for all in
this line the threat to use nuclear
weapons which we will talk about here on
visualpolitik very soon and the attacks
on civilian infrastructure that we saw
at the beginning of this video make a
lot of sense let's just say that
everything makes us suspect that the
Kremlin are perfectly aware that this
time the winter is not in their favor
and is coming but now at this point it's
over to you do you think Russia will
manage to withstand a winter War better
than expected do you think the Ukrainian
should resist the Russian Onslaught
socially and militarily and the energy
blackmail or should they be open to
negotiating with Putin leave us your
options and your opinions in the
comments below and remember if you like
this video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to our channel here so you
don't miss any of our updates you can
also help us create more and better
content by joining our community on
patreon we'll leave you the link in the
description below once again thanks very
much for watching all the best and I'll
see you next time
[Music]